It's different every time.
And if that years ago there wasn't,
I did do something like that at a,
for
a magazine.
Uh,
we're,
we're a journalist's x who followed me
around and we tried to,
but,
um,
it's,
it's slightly different every time.
My inspiration comes from everywhere,
uh,
just walking down the street just,
and I never know where it's going to
come from.
So I keep a notebook with me at all
times.
Um,
and the only criteria for anything
making it into that notebook is if it
stops me in my tracks for even an
instant.
If it catches my eye or my ear,
you know,
and,
and I just write it down.
That means there's,
there are recipes in there,
you know,
there are words and sometimes there's a
character description or sometimes it's
a line.
And after that point though,
what happens is kind of odd.
Um,
I tend to,
I work in fragments in the sense that
I'm not going to sit down and say,
first line is this,
and now I'm going to just write my way
through it.
I let the poem,
it's like piecing it together like a
pot.
So I'll,
I'll might have a line that I might
write down on the middle of a page and I
still write things down with a pen on
paper.
I go to the computer when,
when it gets too messy and use it like
an elaborate typewriter because I
printed out and then I messed it up
again.
But when I do get down,
sit down to write in my room,
in my study and I tried to write there
at a certain time,
every night I'm a night person,
my best times or midnight to six
actually.
Um,
I'll leave through my notebooks and if
something catches my eye and I feel like
I want to transfer it from the notebook
to the page I do.
And then comes this very strange
process,
which is difficult to describe and that
I write until I get stuck or I can't go
any further,
I'm boring myself or whatever.
And then I might go to another poem.
Uh,
I might go to another folder where there
are other drafts of poems in various
stages of completion.
And the only way I have for keeping
track of all this fragment tarry stuff
is by color.
And I have different colored folders,
red folders,
blue,
yellow.
So I might go into my study,
let's say one evening and say I feel
like the blue folder today
and not pick up the blue folder and see
what's in there.
So it's something that I've kind of
worked at over the years,
but the colors are only because I didn't
want to put anything.
I didn't want to file anything in a,
in a straight.
Um,
I think if you put something in a file
that says war poems or loved pumps,
but you already restrict the way in
which the poem might move.
If I put it in blue,
it could be sad blue,
it could be happy blue,
it can be peaceful blue.
But my mood at the moment when I'm about
to work on that poem once will tell me
where I want to go.
So it's an odd process,
but I do do lots of revisions and I love
to revise.
Um,
so 30 40 revisions is not unusual at
this stage.
Uh,
I do most of my revisions by myself
until I reach a point where I either
need to give it lots of time because
time is a great reviser too.
You know,
months of,
of putting it aside or I will show it.
A lot of times I'll show it to my,
my husband who is a novelist and as a
prose writer,
he has a totally different take on
things.
So he comes at it a different way.
Um,
I yearn for those old days,
you know,
both from graduate school,
right?
You go into a workshop and people would
give you all these ideas and you take it
away from me.
But at this point,
um,
that just doesn't,
it's not in the card.
So
I think it's both.
I think that that you certainly don't
have to be aged and you know,
and,
and travel the world to write a poem.
In fact,
sometimes traveling the world is,
is,
is a way of not writing a poem,
but it's the quality of experiences
being able to,
to experience something.
And when you begin to write about it,
be able to apply the tools that you need
for writing,
you know,
a mastery of the language in a way of,
of,
of piecing together the language I
guess,
uh,
that those two factors have to come
together.
So you do need to be to work at it,
but you also have to be able to know
when to,
when to take the experience as it
happened,
went to tweak it a little bit.
What part of the experience is going to
move somebody else.
And what part is really your own?
Um,
private moment.
So I've,
I've seen pumps written by very young
people,
which are absolutely stunning.
And of course we have examples,
look bored layer and you know,
when it was in his teens,
and these are amazing poem.
So he obviously didn't have a wealth of
experience or age or anything like that.
And I've seen poems,
which of course could only have been
written by someone who was older and had
lived certain,
you know,
stages of life.
I've gone through certain stages of
life,
but it's a combination of the two.
It really is.
You know,
I,
I've always felt that,
that the poems I've written,
which have historical context,
um,
are hopefully not just simply plucking
something out of history and saying,
Ooh,
great,
let's write about that in every case.
What has happened is that I've become
fascinated or haunted by something and
couldn't shake it as an African
American,
as a woman,
I think that I've been sensitized to the
way in which history,
uh,
privileges of white male and the way in
which certain aspects of history,
the things that we are taught in school,
the things that are handed down,
never,
never entered the picture that they
might've been very important.
And you want can tell you that,
uh,
at the risk of over simplification,
let me say that anyone can tell you
that,
that how you're raised as a child has a
great deal to do with how you behave as
an adult.
And uh,
whether you have complexes or whether
you need to prove yourself or all kinds
of stuff.
And yet
the mother in a traditional family who
has raised a chuck never makes it in the
history books.
I mean,
so,
so those kinds of things have always
irritated me,
let's put it that way.
And,
um,
and I'm always reminded when I,
when I see someone,
you know,
Napoleon's stocks through the
battlefields,
and I think,
yeah,
but how did he get that way?
You know,
how this guy become who he was.
So that's,
that's the predisposition I had.
I think us as a writer,
as a person,
um,
who wanted to create a poetry,
that's one of the things that has always
been one of my,
um,
the things I carry along with me
each time is different.
For instance,
in this new book,
which is,
uh,
tells the story of,
of,
uh,
black,
mixed race violin is George Bridge Tower
who grew up in 18th and 19th century
Europe.
I came upon him because I was watching a
movie,
immortal,
beloved.
And there was a scene which Beethoven
walks by group of musicians and there's
this black violin.
And so I'm like,
what I've heard of Colin's like casting
this is a bit strange.
And so I looked him up and the,
I didn't intend to write poems about it.
Um,
I just wanted to know more about him and
I kept reading in the more red,
the more I realized the only way I was
going to get him out of my head was to
get into his and start writing by him.
So in each case,
it's,
it's been something like that.
Um.